In 2018, the North American box office has
had its share of high-profile bombs.
There was Solo, the worst-performing Star
Wars movie in the history of Star Wars, and
Skyscraper, the millionth movie Dwayne Johnson's
made this year.
But nothing even comes close to the disastrous
performance of the Chinese film Asura.
Made with a reported budget of $113 million,
Asura debuted to just $7.1 million, and before
the weekend was over, it had been pulled from
theaters.
So, why did China's most expensive movie ever
made bomb so hard at the box office?
What is Asura?
An adaptation of ancient Tibetan legends and
Buddhist mythology, Asura follows a young
man who discovers he's destined to save a
heavenly dimension, which is under attack
by a three-headed king named Asura.
Over the course of his journey, he discovers
he's the reincarnation of one of Asura's heads,
which he'd lost 100 years ago during a previous
invasion attempt.
Asura is about a hero's journey, one that
was pitched as the start of a trilogy, but
it doesn't look like any sequels are coming
anytime soon.
Sabotage
Asura's producers are accusing China's most
prominent film review aggregating websites
of letting users tank the movie's rating with
illegitimate reviews.
There are three sites in China that work as
the equivalent of Rotten Tomatoes and Metacritic.
Asura's early average score on one was an
8.4 out of 10, while the other two registered
at 4.9 and a 3.1.
What explains that discrepancy?
The people behind Asura are convinced that
their movie is the victim of a focused, malicious
attack.
Specifically, the producers claim that they
discovered a large number of 1 out of 10 scores
from suspicious-looking users which were posted
immediately after the film hit theaters.
In an official statement, they have announced,
"Whoever is behind this is dirty, stupid and
ridiculous."
Yanked from theaters
Rather than cut their losses and ride out
the storm, Asura's filmmakers decided to snatch
their movie back out of theaters as quickly
as possible.
Only a few other movies have gotten the hook
in China.
In 2012, Quentin Tarantino's Django Unchained
was unexpectedly pulled from Chinese theaters
literally minutes after being released.
But that was only done for the sake of censorship,
and Django returned to theaters in a matter
of weeks after edits were made.
Asura's situation is entirely different.
It was pulled by the film's own producers,
for the drastic purposes of editing it to
somehow make it better.
But to appreciably raise the movie's quality
through editing would likely take months,
as opposed to weeks.
World-class Effects
One of Asura's biggest attempted innovations
is its larger-than-usual focus on special
effects.
This might seem unusual to American moviegoers,
who are used to seeing state-of-the-art special
effects as a matter of course.
But in the past, Chinese-produced movies typically
haven't had as much money pumped into them.
As a result, their special effects often looked
embarrassingly cheap.
Asura aimed to break that mold.
It seems no expense was spared to bring the
movie's effects to the standard set by American
movies.
That included hiring in-demand, award-winning
Hollywood talent, including veterans of Deadpool,
Lord of the Rings, and Furious 7.
But while the money seems to have all ended
up on screen, it doesn't appear to have been
a good investment.
Middling marketing
Another one of Asura's problems is the sort
of thing that could strike any movie, anywhere:
a lack of effective marketing.
Despite six years' worth of development and
build up, when it came time to actually sell
Asura to potential audiences, it looks like
the ball got dropped at a critical moment.
At least, that's one claim that's been circulating,
stemming from Chinese market analysts.
According to a representative of Beijing-based
showbiz market research firm Fankink,
"Based on our tracking, prerelease market
heat for this movie was quite low, below average."
Regardless of whether or not that's an accurate
assessment of the situation, Asura now has
a reputation as a movie almost nobody wanted
to see.
Untested director
What else could have gone wrong here?
For one thing, director Peng Zhang is an untested
quantity.
Though he's been a stunt coordinator for many
Hollywood productions, including Wonder Woman,
The Last Samurai, and Rush Hour 3, Asura is
his first ever project as director.
Think about that for a second: What's purported
to be the most expensive film ever made in
the history of China was directed by a person
who had never directed a movie before in his
life.
We're not saying Asura's failure is Zhang's
fault.
We're just pointing out that a first-time
director seems like an incredibly strange
choice to head up such an expensive, high-stakes
production.